i don't want to be around the bush have
you heard of the save ima norway masjid
project your brothers and sisters at
islam that are establishing a one of his
kind masjid tawa and community center in
the capital of norway and they need our
urgent support now every person that
accepts islam through this center every
revert who learns about their deen and
calls their family to the worship of
allah you will get the rewards inshallah
so here's what you must do you must
contribute to get your rewards and share
this project imagine you're meeting
allah subhanahu ta'ala and receiving the
glad tidings of a palace in jannah
because of this very masjid you built
with your sabaka now you tell me what
greater joy can there be than getting a
house in jannah with gardens and rivers
of honey walls built of bricks of gold
and silver mortar of fragrant musk
pebbles of pearl and sapphire and soil
of saffron and whoever enters the house
in jannah will be filled with joy and
will never feel miserable they will live
there forever and they will never die
they will get clothes that will never
wear out and the youth will never fade
away
subhanallah these are the descriptions
of the houses in jannah that our beloved
prophet peace be upon him gave to his
beloved companions would you not want
that for your afterlife click the button
to donate and earn this tremendous
reward inshallah and don't forget to
share the video